what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and we
have the final trailer for morbius day
now they did some reshoots recently and
there have been some rumors that they're
going to add certain characters into the
movie perhaps maybe andrew garfield
spider-man i don't think if they did
that we'll see it right here but let's
take a look at what the final trailer
for morbius has to offer
michael morbius discover who you're
meant to be
the bad
guy i thought he said batman for a
second the bad guy
yes
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but a cure
that can only be described as
superhumans
but there's a cost
now a face of choice
to hunt
and consume blood
or die
we all have monsters within us
it's up to us to control it
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
who the real bad guy is yes
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st a new marvel
legend arrives
well i'm excited for morbius i'm
concerned for morbius i i want it to be
a good movie obviously and from what
i've seen in the trailers it looks like
it can be a good movie but we've seen
trailers show us all the best parts
before and then the movie is somewhat
mediocre i'm really excited for this
darker kind of side this isn't the mcu
right so i can't say like i'm excited
for the darker side of the mcu but the
kind of darker marvel movies and morbius
is a really fascinating character uh
jared leto is an amazing actor and i
think he's got a lot of skills and i
think he can play this character very
very well i just i'm excited for the
movie i think he's gonna do well and i
hope the movie does well i hope they
went in a really good direction with
this and i'm actually hoping that there
is somewhat of a crossover in the mcu we
see michael keaton in this one and i
want to know what this all means because
sony clearly has a plan for this right
uh we didn't see michael keaton we
didn't really see anybody in spider-man
no way home all of the villains came
from you know the older spider-man
universes so i'm excited to see what
their actual plan
for all the villains is and the
crossover into the mcu so let me know
what you think about this final trailer
in the comments down below and if you
have an idea of what sony's plan could
be let me know what you think about that
as well don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest marvel news as always
i'll see you next time woof